i thought would be interesting and
inspirational to maybe do a video on how
i paid off my mortgage
but i didn't go into lots of details and
there was a lot of questions about it
and your name was brought up a lot
yeah there was actually someone who did
like a reaction video it was like
i don't think she paid off her mortgage
i think something or the other
i watch samuel leeds and he talks about
this kind of stuff
so here we are and here and actually i
think that is how i found out about you
or maybe i'd seen
your videos before then but yes um i'm
into saving money being good with money
and then into poverty as well your whole
brand and start is
people know that you're an inspiring
you're a business woman you're not just
you are you're a business woman yeah
you're smart and you and you're good
with money
so you know what was the reaction to
that video generally was it very
positive
it was very very positive there was an
element of confusion
and people also not entirely
understanding how it's possible
and i i used to see comments of people
saying well that's because you're a
youtuber
only you can do that and that was one of
the things that would bug me because i
i would respond to comments i said no
not only me does this i like
i come from an immigrant background my
mom's a hustler
and she's done it so it's not just
because i was a youtuber i was able to
pay off a property it's just because
i've yeah i made a lot of money mom's
doing really well though uh yeah yeah
she's kind of slowing down now selling a
lot of stuff and just trying to live her
best life
he said new video she came into the uk
as an immigrant yeah and now she has 10
houses in the uk
exactly which is it just shows that you
can start with nothing but if you're
prepared to hustle yeah you're paid to
work hard
yeah and and anything really exactly and
if you're smart about
moves that you make then you're able to
learn about how this stuff works and
actually
what i started quite early so my mom i
think she went on to a property course
or she met someone who was into it who
told her to buy
a house she had a council property and
she bought it for 17
000 and then sold it for 250 000 and
then used that money to buy other houses
and so i was with her during that whole
journey so i watched her when i was like
15
kind of go from zero to like oh to all
of this
so i knew it was very possible and then
i used to manage
her properties in manchester when i was
at uni so she had four properties
and i would be writing contracts and
going to see tenants and all this kind
of stuff so
i was obviously having fun at uni but i
was also doing this
as well so i was very familiar with the
process and knew that it was possible
yeah for sure
and you're not just it wasn't just that
one house you've gone on to buy more
houses and now you're a property
investor
patricia the property investor yeah kind
of i haven't shared
much about that and i'm very new to
i want to say new to doing it myself but
i don't i don't know all the details of
doing it i'm sure you're like the expert
i've seen you doing this like the houses
of multiple occupancy and yeah
these ever other technical stuff that
i'm like i don't even know what this is
you said to me that you said to me just
before we started off camera the best
advice i could give right now to anybody
would be to spend 24 minutes
watching the exclusive interview with
patricia bryce it's one of the most
inspiring
interviews you'll ever watch patricia is
amazing check it out
watch the full video in the link